what's going on guys today we're going
to be ranking the top 10 anime original
quirks from micro academia as the title
suggests these abilities are ones that
did not originate from the manga like
most quirks do but instead they only
appear for the first time in filler
episodes ovas and of course the movies
as well before we get into it it should
be said that the different pals in this
video will be ranked from most
interesting to least interesting in my
opinion so the position isn't
necessarily based on how powerful they
might be also any anime original quirks
that have already shown up in my
previous top 10 videos won't be in this
one but if you want to see those then my
place featuring all my top tens is in
the description below
okay so starting in first place we have
zombie virus which is an ability that
first appeared in the training of the
dead ova in that episode class one took
part in a survival exercise alongside
four students from another academy and
among them was this bakago type
character called fajumi who ended up
clashing with the real back of go
multiple times his zombie virus quirk
was by far the most interesting out of
his classmates as it enables him to
produce a pink gas from his body that
zombifies anyone who breathes it in for
a period of time the people infected
become indestructible but lose all brain
activity to the point where they have no
control over their quirks and have been
shown to move in random ways the zombies
can then pass the virus to other people
through biting meaning it could easily
be spread to areas where fujimi's gas
didn't initially reach
despite apparently having no brain
activity many of the infected
instinctively retained parts of their
core personality with zombie moneta
doing things that only he would do and
the same was true for other characters
as well this brings us to the downsides
of the quirk which is that fujimi
himself seemingly has no control over
his creations as the affected are free
to do whatever they want including
biting him when this happens he
transforms into a zombie like anyone
else and he's also clearly not immune
from the effects of his pink gas hence
why his costume has a mask covering his
mouth and nose show to imply that if
fujimi's in his normal state then he's
able to reverse the effects of the virus
in other people however this was just an
assumption and we don't know for sure
what we do know is that in the ova the
infected will return back to normal
simultaneously when the time went out
with throppy and fujiumi being zombies
for a shorter period of time than other
people this indicates that once the
first zombie goes back to normal then
all the others do as well regardless of
when they were infected but again this
is speculation based on what we've seen
overall i think a power like this would
be best in the hands of a villain who
wants to cause widespread chaos but for
a hero i am curious to see how this
could be helpful in a normal situation
next up is chimera who is a villain that
had a quirk of the same name during the
hero's rising movie and one of the
things that makes this power great is
that it's essentially a hybrid between
the three main types of quirks those
being mutant emitter and transformation
types mutation quirks are ones where the
owner has a permanent physical
abnormality and chimera satisfies that
requirement by having the head of a wolf
the tail of what i assume is a dragon
and his hands and feet resemble the
cause of an eagle
by contrast a transformation quirk is
one that enables the user to temporarily
change their body in some way and
chimera meets that requirement too as he
has a dragon ball style power up where
his muscle mass drastically increases
alongside his feathers his tail and
pretty much everything else about him
finally emitter quirks are powers that
can be turned on and off and don't
usually change the way the user looks
and chimera being able to breathe fire
is a classic example of that type of
ability on top of that he has superhuman
strength even when in his base form as
shown when he broke the ground with a
single step destroyed this vehicle with
a shove and easily held of classman
without much problem
if we're being real his natural raw
strength is probably higher than the
number one hero as i can't imagine
endeavour doing some of these things
without the assistance of his fire
speaking of fire when chimera does his
transformation his flame breath turns
into a more concentrated beam of energy
that in my opinion only strengthens the
dragon ball comparison i genuinely
wouldn't be surprised if we had seen
this guy in the tournament of power
because you know in all honesty he just
looks like a character from that series
who was then brought into my academia
in third place is the quirk known as
eagle but the most interesting thing
about this is not the power itself but
rather the backstory surrounding the
character the third person in question
is called takahiro and according to
rokoshi he was originally meant to be
the number two hero in japan takihiro is
technically an anime original character
given that his first appearance in the
universe came in the two heroes movie
and to this day he's yet to make an
appearance in the actual manga that
being said in volume 20 harukoshi
explained that this character is from a
previous manga he had written called
omagadoki zoo and he was 100 going to
use this design for the character we now
know as hawks
according to him the reason this didn't
happen is that when they were working on
the two heroes movie one of the anime
staff had raided magurokizu and asked if
they could use takhiro in the film
itself he said that he was incredibly
moved that someone loved his previous
work and gave his consent for takahiro
to appear with a knock-on effect being
that hawks now had to be redesigned
while the full details of his eagle
quirk are unknown it's safe for us to
assume that had he not been used in the
movie it would have been the exact same
as hawks's fierce wings let me know in
the comments if you think oriko she made
the right decision by changing the
design or do you think he should have
stuck with hakuhiro so that tokyoyami
could have had a mentor with a birdhead
like him moving on we have the iq quirk
used by saeko intelli who is a second
year student that appeared during the
provisional license exam intelli is from
a hero academy that appears to be a
female only school and her regular iq
score is 150 which is way ahead of the
average in japan which is 104
by drinking tea our quirk allows her to
temporarily multiply her iq and
according to president mike's
description different brands of tea have
different effects on how much smarter
she becomes
while this isn't the first intelligence
related quote we've seen it is the first
one that has a virtually unlimited
potential because in theory with the
right brand of tea her iq could keep
multiplying to a level never reached
before by any human
when she came up against class a she
devised a plan to make jira froppy and
shoji useless with the intention being
that momo would then be forced to
exhaust her quirk until she had nothing
left
this particular plan didn't work since
sayiko incorrectly thought that yayarosu
wouldn't use her creation to attack so
i'm going to assume the brand of
teaching that day must have just been
terrible
on a separate note the name saeko is a
reference to a similar word that means
maximum or highest and when you combine
that with her surname overall it means
something like greatest intelligence
in fifth place is the transformation
quirk known as whole body lens that was
used by this journalist who appeared in
the filler in season 4. the power
enables him to produce an unlimited
amount of camera lenses anywhere on his
body which as you would expect are able
to take pictures the images taken are
presumably stored in his brain like an
sd card but when he wants to he can
materialize the pictures by printing
them out of his chest
as we can see here the lenses are not
all the same as they come in different
shapes and sizes so if he really tried
who knows how big they could actually go
although this is purely my speculation i
feel like whole body lens is a more
limited version of momo's creation quirk
where he can convert the lipids in his
body into camera lenses and pictures but
nothing else that's the way i prefer to
think about it at least because i guess
the alternative is that he has a bunch
of camera lenses inside of him and uh
yeah that would be pretty gross
up next is spotted seal which is a quote
used by selkie who is one of the few
anime original characters to make
multiple appearances and one of the few
heroes that works almost exclusively on
the water
similar to chimera he has a superhuman
level of strength compared to a normal
person but the real reason he's on this
list is because of his echolocation by
making a clicking sound with his mouth
the noise then reflects off nearby
objects and comes back to him enabling
him to know exactly how far away things
are this was demonstrated in season 2
when he literally fought against this
octopus man while being completely
blinded and again in season 5 he was
able to move freely despite there being
a smoke screen blocking his vision
the clicking noises he makes can then be
used to send coded messages at a high
frequency bringing us to the seventh
anime original quirk on this list
selkie's main psychic is a hero called
sirius and her quirk allows her to hear
high frequencies that normal people
can't detect that means he can often
send her detailed coded instructions
that no one else can hear and what's
most impressive is the distances over
which they communicate on one occasion i
say he was at least a couple hundred
meters away from her but on the boat she
could still hear his crits coming from
underneath the water to me that's
incredibly impressive however the plot
twist is that her real ears just look
like anyone else's ears and the things
she has on her head are just radio
devices
in eighth place we have a quirk from the
hero's rising movie again and this time
we're talking about mummification by
manipulating the bandages covering his
body mommy can convert any inanimate
object into a monster that he controls
like a puppet master his creations grow
limbs once they've been wrapped up and
even super heavy objects can be
converted and then lifted into the air
without much effort the big downside is
that they're not that durable and can be
destroyed pretty easily but the villain
makes up for this by having strength in
numbers given that there's seemingly no
limit to how many he can make at one
time
while these red bandages are unable to
directly control people they can't
control the unanimous objects that
people wear such as clothes and hero
support items this is why bakago was
able to be restrained by this ability
and he was only able to escape by
blowing up one of his gauntlets showing
that mummification can't prevent people
from using their own power
moving on to the penultimate quark on
this list we have an unnamed one from
the training of the dead ova that was
used by dad and taran this guy is a
student from isumi high school same as
for jumi and because of his quirk he was
constantly sweating from the moment he
was introduced so much so that he
carries around a handkerchief to wipe it
away
to me his design is very clearly
inspired by tintin as his dotted eyes
and ginger hair make him even more
similar to the character than mirio
while we never got a description of his
quirk it's implied his sweat produces a
flashbang effect and his mech suit
produces rockets filled with that sweat
that can be used to blind the enemy it's
possible that like bakago is sweat has
more applications than just the
flashbang but until we get some new
information about this character there's
no confirmation either way i gotta say
his hero costume is by far one of the
biggest and most elaborate ones we've
ever seen like not just students but pro
heroes as well so you know it just goes
to show that other schools besides ua
and shigetsu have a big budget as well
finally the last quirk belongs to electo
plant who's a long-standing hero based
in california that's been active for at
least 40 years in two heroes he was seen
working during all my time in america
and then in chapter 303 his silhouette
made its first official appearance in
the manga confirming that he's yet to
retire from what we've seen his quirk is
a more refined version of kaminaris as
he can generate electricity and shoot it
out of his hand like a lightning bolt
which is obviously more precise than
anything denki is able to do without his
support items
if alexa plant does eventually come to
japan i mean it would be pretty amazing
if denki was able to intern with him but
then again the last time i suggested a
student in terms with the hero that
person ended up dying during the war arc
so uh maybe maybe electrical punch
shouldn't come over to japan anyway guys
if you enjoyed the video then be sure to
hit that sub button if you haven't
already and drop a like as it helps me
out and let me know in the comments
which anime original quirks are your
personal favorites
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out